thing for 45 seconds last time
anywho mission impossible dead
reckoning i'm excited i love love this
franchise and i love me some tommy cruz
we are the gold standard so leave a like if
you can that would be very much appreciated
subscribe click the notification
bell because we got a lot coming up
uh starting at the end of this week oh boy so
much coming your way guys let's get into this
oh nice like a james bond theme song days
of fighting for the so-called greater good
are over hey
this is our chance to control the
truth the concepts of right and wrong
hey like for centuries to come you're fighting
to save an ideal that doesn't exist my patch
never did you need to pick a sign oh
my god it's mirroring the first movie
the mummy i know i can't
think of that throughout this
oh this is the magic hour mission impossible
shay wiggum
yes
doctors
i think they actually destroyed that bridge
wow wow sexy ah and then tom just hits
right into the ground yeah i like to see
from the other guys when they jump
off the rooftop the only way faith
wants to go out is in a place of innocence
who's been promoting top gun in this race
it's just a cg model who got him scanned in
that's insane my nipples got so chilly so early on
god that last stunt is crazy he's supposed to go
into a parachute right now that's just fine like
superhero landing yeah yeah he's gonna have one
of those batman flight suits there are surprising
amount of callbacks to the first movie in this
one i mean not only do you have what's that
actor's name henry cherny oh wow you just whipped
that one out having him back there and a sit down
and conversation across him that's the scene
in the first movie when they had puts the gum
on the mirror and on the water tank and that back
then was a big dunker style like oh my god that's
insane now it's like nothing for doctors yeah
climb back to that scene even at one point with
the key with haley atwood there's like a magic
reveal like i don't know i call him doing that in
any of the other movies but the first one yeah one
fighting on top of the train on top of the train
it's very much reminiscent of the first movie
which is often uh i think that one is a kind of
an unrecognized one in this franchise because
that one's not much action it's mainly just
you know espionage dialogue driven and where
you know it's become much more of an action
franchise so it's cool to see it you know really
embodying those things christian core is a hell
of a writer so to see it going back to a little
more of those and i think you got to have a more
intense expansive story especially if you are
making this a two-parter i don't know if part
eight is going to be called dead reckoning too
but this is essentially a part one to the last
the last two months in this franchise but it looks
uh along the lines of what i've been loving about
the mission of possible franchise since mccoy
took over keeping the action very vital and very
intense but also keeping it dark the ensemble's
so big it's so big now yeah it's like morphed into
a show again or the first one was we're getting
rid of all the cats yes and then we're just gonna
zero in on a few people yeah and this one has a
big ensemble again it got like everyone vanessa
kirby rebecca ferguson straight out of metal gear
solid yeah yeah absolutely you got benji and you
got luther yeah haley atwell for sure is michelle
monaghan gonna be coming back i hope so she's just
they're gonna have to go and bother her again
saving the world doing her philanthropic work
i thought like he would eventually end up with
rebecca ferguson but it looks like a lot of the
romantic chemistry is going to be coming in the
form of haley atwell who do you choose tom i know
hopefully you've got some both action-oriented
and acting-oriented leading ladies to choose from
they should be the polyamorous ethan hunters
that's who we should get you also have your
your wife who i'm sure still very much
worried about you at all times she's
around i hope that the last very last movie comes
all the way back there we got to save your old
wife you know jeremy renner well he they gotta
find a way maybe they'll surprise us maybe he'll
step in when you least expect it or something
and one of our loyal subscribers raghu who i know
is here in the comments right now he mentioned
that there were vibes of this trailer that gave a
lawrence of arabia vibe not so much not gonna
work for me no man no no that's the end of the
mummy right there this is the continuation of
that franchise as well nick arcs into ethan hunt
remember nick that's right man that's your
favorite mummy now that's my the definitive mummy
as far as i'm concerned and he did say that palm
clementine was in this movie as well and i think
that's who the one asian girl fighting who as an
assassin is that would make a lot of sense yeah
that bleach blonde hairdo and this one they all
get kind of political but this one seems to be the
most overtly political at least in the marketing
for mission impossible the movies tend to have
some type of it's not no one's a big takeaway
a mission apostle tends to be the political
aspects of it so i don't hear people [__] about
it but here they seem to really lean heavily on it
because they're talking about like controlling
the ideals and that did get metal gear solid vibes
honestly a lot of this so it seems to me at least
they're on the brink of a some type of big-ass war
breaking out well yeah or just like worldwide
unrest and i get the sense yeah to make it very
modern it's probably some kind of mcguffin or or
world ending stake scenario that has something to
do with information and the distribution thereof
they're fighting fox news and cnbc and exactly
they're fighting on and everybody but kind of i
mean you know i'm sure they'll make some kind of
grand sci-fi macguffin out of all that stuff but
yeah i mean that's very relevant to the now and i
feel like the further we get through these movies
you know you have biological warfare you have
geopolitical tensions you have ecological things
and and james even if you look at james bond
movies they often derive their big bads from those
things too but there's a bond fleur to it yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i mean you know i'm sure that
comes from the intermingling of both franchises
influencing each other as they move forward sure
sure yeah but yeah there is something that looks
while incredibly action-packed as per the earmarks
of mission impossible like it will also have more
of that james bond not to even slight the previous
mission impossibles though because they can get
pretty intricate in terms of the plotting they
want you to follow yeah but yeah this definitely
had some of that elegance and i think the choice
to do most of the trailer set to music and really
choose when to use sound effects and when to use
dialogue helps to enhance that level of elegance
almost even though everything you're seeing is so
rough and tumble but i thought this trailer was
great i mean that final stunt though looks crazy
but i feel like there's probably something even
bigger in store yeah well it looks like it's
a good write as much as we've talked about it
hearkening back to the first film it definitely
does but it seems like two they're coming through
the entire history yeah and all the different
where are the dumps and places and the dueling
motorcycle we might get a knife very close to an
eye because my prediction would be that rebecca
ferguson has to lose that eye in the knife fight
oh yeah probably never forget and never forget
only use guns from now on all right people well
what'd you think leave your thoughts down below we
watched top gun maverick this week as well a lot
of tom cruise and obi-wan and stranger things yeah